hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's the
finals of the Magnus Invitational Magnus
Carlsen
versus Hikaru Nakamura and already Game
one is is quite the thriller not not
gonna spoil too much but before we check
it out here I prepared these are the
stats between the two of them so far in
their head-to-head record so as you can
see in classical games Magnus is quite
the favorite as he beat he karo 14 to 1
with 25 draws but if we check only rapid
and exhibition games Carlsen beat Hiro
Nakamura 42 to 18 with 37 draw so Magnus
still the favorite in in every time
format but we'll see we'll see how this
one goes so in the first game Magnus has
the white pieces and he opens the width
c4 so he goes for the English opening
and we have E 5 Knight to c3 and again
we will see the the four Knights of the
English night of 692 ft 3 in the knight
to c6 same as a Nakamura played against
the ding in their Armageddon game here
in the invitational so g3 and d5
immediately striking in the center the
same way he did against dink captures
captures and Bishop the g2 now just
putting putting the bishop on des this
nice diagonal we have nice to b6 going
for for the main line and now castles by
white we have Bishop to e7 continuing
development and d3 now we have castles
and now Bishop to e3
so our Magnus continue in the same
fashion dink played against Nakamura
with Bishop to e6 and now rook the c1
this is one of one of one difference
being did not go for this rook to see
one idea later on he wanted to develop
his quintet to a4 instead so Knight back
to d5 now wanting to trade of this
Knight which is which is weird because
you've just removed it to the b6 but
this is how it is played today that's
okay we have characters captors and a3
now and rook to e8 and here Queen to c2
like I said in that game ding went for
Queen to a4 against Nakamura and it was
almost this exact same position only the
rook was an a1 we're doing plate Queen
to a4 but here we have the included rope
to c1 and the Magnus develops the Queen
to c2 and it's not a new move this
has been reached before but in in some
other games so Queen to d7 is a no move
here but Bishop to f6 the move Nakamura
played is a new move so already as I've
moved 13 we have a completely new game
so let's see how Magnus deals with it he
first goes Knight 2 d2 offers a trade of
light square bishop seer but he also
abandons the d4 square so nakamura finds
a very interesting way of how to
exchange a lot of pieces he goes night
to d4 which already threatens Knight
captures an e2 which would come with
checks we don't have time to grab the c7
pawn so first bishop character Sundy for
we have Bishop captures and g2 King
captures and now E characters and d4
trying to trade at this point for this
pawn so Magnus goes for it and the man
who spent quite a lot of time here
Magnus spent some 5 minutes and he was
already down to 10 minutes whereas
Hikaru had his full 15 minutes so he
carved pretty much just blitzed out
every move so Queen captures on c7 rook
captures an e2 in now concentrates
Queens we have Queen captures rook
captures and now Magnus has to decide
how to deal with this his knight is
under attack and also if the knight
moves the pawn could be under attack so
first Knight to c4 asking that do you
want to play b5 but B 5 here doesn't
really do the job since yes you are kind
of threatening if the knight moves
you're gonna grab this pawn but you have
King f3 now going after the rook and
after the rook is defended now you have
nice to b6 just winning the game on the
spot because the only way for the rook
the guard district is to remain on the
e-file and if you remain on the e-file
then you just get looked to see it check
and it's game over you have to block and
that's just it white wins
so instead Nakamura first the doubles up
on the e-file and now Magnus goes for
King to f3
so trying to set up the exact same thing
if b5 Knight to d6 just wins but Hikaru
of course not doesn't offer and we have
Bishop to g5 attacking the rook and now
rook the b1 kind of a passive Square for
the rook but Magnus plans to start
pushing on the Queen side so the rookin
b1 will actually be useful we have
looked back the e6 by Hikaru and not
just a for he wants to start pushing on
the Queen side we have h5 Nakamura wants
to play someone like
if six check fall by rook to e2 and put
pressure on the f2 pawn and he doesn't
want to allow Magnus to escape to the g4
square so first h5 and now Magnus
continues pushing on the Queen side will
be four and g6 now preparing to improve
the position of the king with b5 by
Magnus and now King to g7 we have looked
the b2 preparing to bring the other
Brooke over either to be one or maybe
maybe to c1 then c2 to keep control over
the second rank we have Bishop back to
e7 by Nakamura may be considering a
blockade here would be b6 and Bishop to
c5 but Magnus continues with rook to c1
not going for rook the b1 so probably
rook rook to c2 is an idea with g5 by
Nakamura now preparing g4 to force the
King back and Magnus does it voluntarily
we have King to g2 and now g4 and now we
have rook c2 c2 which could be kind of
dangerous
if Nakamura for example gets his rooks
on the back rank and the other Brooke
also comes the one then work to g1 will
be made because the pawn prevents the
King from escaping
so maybe are also a thing to consider
better back to g5 by Nakamura and here
Magnus finds a very interesting
breakthrough which is a made possible by
Nakamura's Bishop to g5 he pushes b6
which is very interesting because if you
block it then you get Knight to a5 just
going after the b7 pawn and let's say
you wanna we wanna trade pawns here then
the route comes to see it and it's a
very complicated position where white
definitely achieved a lot so instead the
Nakamura goes a captures and b6 and now
not captures right away but first rugby
5 threatening the bishop here and also
if the bishop moves you you will just
gobble up the h5 pawn so King g6
defending and now f4 just going after
that Bishop which if Hikaru captures up
a song then across and no longer has to
worry about getting checkmated which he
does and you don't really have the
option of moving the blusher because
just f5 check wins on the spot so after
f4 we have G captures on f3 and now King
captures on f3 with the show back to d8
now defending the b6 pawn and here cross
and either puts more
on the B sex pond or he goes for work to
d5 which happened in the game he goes
after the d4 pawn so push her back to f6
defending it and only not worked a b2
again with more pressure on the b6 pawn
now Hikaru goes for the a4 pawn we have
rook to e8 and here crossing has to
decide does he want to capture with the
night and to keep the tension defend the
e4 pawn or he goes for rook captures and
b6 which happened in the game so he
wants to trade we have rook captures on
a4 and now rook captures on e6 with F
captures and e6 and now rook back to b5
again going after the b7 pawn nakamura
goes rook to a-1 magnus grabs the pawn
and now rook the f1 with check with came
to e2 and now a rook to h1 Magnus
defends with h4 we have rook to g1 goes
after the pawn and now King f2 but now
rook to d1 and now Magnus has to decide
where he wants to go back and back and
forth between e 2 and F 2 and the draw
the game by repetition or rook the b3
which happened in the game he says nope
we continue the game and now Nakamura
goes back look to a-1 if you try and
gain some activity with your King then
you get some Knight d6 checking g4 and
knights the e4 could also it's hard to
decide whether this is good or bad for
black but you don't want your King stuck
somewhere like like this
so instead nakamura goes rogue back to
8:1 and now Knight to d6 now Magnus will
shift his Knight over to e4
so Bishop to e5 attacking in the night
putting pressure on the g3 pawn Knight
to e4 and now rook to a5
so he says what what's your plan Magnus
Magnus goes king to have three we have
King to f5 now and now Knight back to d2
going for for c4 once again
Bishop back to f6 we have knife to c4n
again
rook to a 1 so he collar says what what
are we doing here
Magnus goes for Knight to d6 check King
back to g6 and now again tonight back
the e4 and rook to e1 again by Hikaru
so of course he car doesn't mind trading
into into a rook and pawn and game so
King to f2 pushes the route back and
look at the e3 now again you might have
some
problems here official comes to e5 and
not to there and goes after the the g3
pony or not and night will be stuck here
but Magnus not interested he goes
Knights to d2 and looked he 5 now we
have night back that efore and now rook
the f5 with check King e2 and now look
back the a5 we have looked the b6 by
Magnus going after the e6 pawn now and
King f5 just defending with King to f3
and Basha back to e5 so again what
what's cost and doing here we have
looked back to b3 just adding a defender
to the pawn here waiting to see what he
car will do and Hikaru goes for look to
a-1 once again we have worked the b5 and
now rook to e1 by Hikaru with Knight to
d6 width check now there's a pin so you
cannot capture kink the g6 not King f6
to allow some nights to e4 check ideas
so King g6 and now Knight the c4 by
Magnus with a double attack on the
bishop there was also the disgusting
engine Lion King f2 which results in 2
if you want to keep defending the Bishop
rook III and then in 94 with a double
attack and after Bishop captures and g3
with Chef now you play King G 2 and
there's no way for the rook to be
defended you either move it and and you
lose this guy over here either you
capture here or then rook the g5 check
picks up the bishop or you capture here
and then you give up the exchange and ID
captures the d captures here but then
rookie v defense and well why should
what should be a lot better but it's
hard to decide whether you can actually
win this so of course Magnus goes for
Knights the c4 instead and now rush back
to f6
we have worked the b6 by Magnus again
going after the pawn for the moment the
rogue defends it and King to f5 we have
King to f2 and now rook to d1 putting
pressure on the d3 pawn Knight the d6
check and here he car decides that you
maybe he will will trade some points so
we have King to g4 and now Knight to e4
attacking the bishop and the pawn here
and Bishop to e5 here here he karo gives
up the e6 pawn Magnus grabs
and now King back to f5 just attacking
the rock first and then only then do you
capture and III however Magnus also has
King to e2 now forcing well not forcing
but offering a trade of rooks which
Hikaru declines again says do we go for
a repetition here but Magnus now goes
rook to h6 it goes after this pawn and
ok Hikaru has no other option but the
capture on g3 with rook captures on h5
first with check King f4 and now rook
the h8 getting the rock out of the way
so he can start pushing his past h-bond
and all of a sudden it's Magnus who is
up upon with rook to e1 check came to d2
and now comes rook to e3 preparing
Bishop to e1 check but Magnus just
starts pushing the pawn we have Bishop
to e1 which check King C - and now rook
to h3 and here it was already very
dangerous because now a seeker who is
extremely low on time he had some 15
seconds on the clock and here just h6 by
Magnus and Hikaru goes after the pawn
king f5 we have h7 by Magnus and King to
g6 but this is now completely lost for
Hikaru so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning move while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on supporting at this
beautiful tactic and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook g8 check you give up the pawn
Hikaru grab the pond and Magnus just
went Knight f6 check King to h6 is
forced and now you just win the rook
rook checks King to g6 going after the
night and now it's just a trade captures
captures and now it's a rook against the
bishop which if you know how to how to
win then of course it is winning and the
Magnus knows how to play this King b3
King G 5 we have King to c4 and out just
Bishop to f2 the defending the pawn we
have grouped the f3 Bishop to e3 and now
rook their fate now the point is you
need to kick the King away from the
e-file and then you will just sacrifice
well not sacrifice the trader look for
for pawn and the bishop so King e6 and
now King the c5 we have Bishop back to
g1 and King to c6 now we have Bishop
III and only not rookie 8 check so the
King has to move but it was also in this
position unmoved 84 that he called
Nakamura resigned the game as he knows
that this is completely winning just to
show you how after the king moves you're
gonna go rook to e4 after looking moves
once again King d5 and now once the King
moves again you just pick up the pawn
and that's it after this trade it's of
course completely winning king e7 you're
gonna go king D 5 king deservin but now
you have a pawn push King g7 you're
gonna go King to c6 here you grab the
opposition the King to e8 and now it's
just the force completely winning but
yeah of course he carved knows that and
after this rook T check move he resigned
the game so game 1 of the Magnus
Invitational finals goes to Magnus
Carlsen so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Christian Zeiler our shooters Parrikar
and Melvin Melvin Java Sebastian boom in
the niels wild for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it also it's Niels wilds
birthday so I wish you all the best me
win many many games and have a great day
and yeah yeah that's it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the finals until it finishes
see you soon